كانوا غارقين في المعاناه التي خلفتها
كارثه الزلزال فجاءت الفيضانات
اوقات عصيبه عاشها هذا الرجل وعائلته فبعد
دقائق الزلزال المرعبه هدرت الفيضانات
الجارفه جينا من ملاط
ين شايف الحاله هون كمان صار عنا فيضانات
الحمد لله
انه في غيرنا راحوا بالسيل في الضحايا
راحوا بالسيل يعني
الله كاتب علينا ما بنعرف شو بدنا نساوي
يعني لهلا هاي حالتنا
بعض ما صمد من منازل ايام الزلزال اغرقت
الفيضانات اكثرها
نفس انت تتوق الى النجاح
لكن هناك خرابه ومن نجوا وجدوا انفسهم في
العراق
وصلت الفيضانات الى هذا الارتفاع وكانت
الساعه الثامنه صباحا وبقينا محاصرين مع
الجيران لعده ساعات الاوضاع كما ترون لم
يبقى لدينا شيء هذا هو حالنا
اودت الفيضانات بحياه عدد من الاشخاص في
اورفا
وثمه مفقودون تواصل فرق الانقاذ وقوات من
الجيش والدرك والشرطه البحث عنهم امل
المتضررين ان تكون الكوارث الاخيره مجرد
ذكرى اليمه بعد تجاوز تداعياتها
استمروا عمليات الانقاذ تحذر هيئه الارصاد
الجويه التركيه من ان الامطار الغزيره
ستستمر لعده ايام وهو ما قد يزيد من صعوبه
الاوضاع ومعاناه المواطنين خصوصا النازحين
والمتضررين من كارثه الزلزال والفيضانات
عمرو حلبي الجزيره محافظه اورفا جنوبيه
تركيا